bien je vous propose que que nous
commençons et en l'absence du président
rénal et il me reviennent de présider
cette cette réunion de ce matin mes
chers
collègues madame la secrétaire général
dans votre fonction actuelle
nous recevons aujourd'hui donc en vertu
de la loi organique du 23 juillet 2010
relative à l'application du cinquième
alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution madame Marianne barbalayani
dans le président de la République
propose la nomination en fonction de
président de l'Autorité des marchés
financiers
le mandat de Monsieur Robert hoffel que
nous avions entendu le 6 juillet dernier
pour qu'il nous expose notamment le
bilan de son action à la tête de la MF
en effet expiré fin juillet et je
rappelle que la présidence de la MF
correspond à un mandat non renouvelable
de 5 ans
comme vous le savez la MF est une
autorité publique indépendante qui a
pour mission de veiller à la protection
de l'épargne investie en produits
financiers à l'information des
investisseurs et au bon fonctionnement
des marchés vous avez tous reçu le CV de
Madame Barbara
que je vais inviter à nous exposer les
raisons ayant motivé sa candidature et
ce qu'elle entend proposer pour
l'exercice du mandat qui lui serait
éventuellement confié puis j'inviterai
notre rapporteur désigné pour cette
audition c'est albéric de Montgolfier a
lui poser les premières questions et
enfin nous aurons comme à la coutumée un
débat
je veux rappeler que les délégations de
vote ne sont pas autorisées et seuls les
sénateurs présents physiquement pourront
prendre par robot à bulletin secret à la
fin de cette réunion en vertu du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 à
Constitution le président de la
République ne pourrait procéder à cette
nomination si l'addition des votes
négatifs exprimées dans les commissions
des finances des œufs deux assemblées
représentés au total au moins les 3/5
des suffrages exprimés madame barbal
ayani a été entendu la semaine dernière
par la commission des finances de
l'Assemblée nationale et le
dépouillement simultané aura lieu demain
à 9 heures
et Marc Lamini secrétaire du bureau
massisteront pour se dépouillement comme
scrutateur
les résultats seront donc connus demain
matin
je vous rappelle enfin que conformément
à la loi du 23 juillet 2010 7 audition
est publique et retransmise en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat je vous
souhaite donc la parole pour un propos
introductif avant que nous procédons aux
questions comme à l'habitude
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les membres de la commission
comme monsieur le Président vient de le
rappeler le président de la République
m'a fait l'honneur d'envisager de me
nommer président de l'Autorité des
marchés financiers votre commission doit
se prononcer sur cette nomination
conjointement avec celle de l'Assemblée
nationale la commission des finances qui
m'a en effet auditionnée la semaine
dernière
sur ce sujet
cette procédure à mes yeux montre
l'importance à la fois de la fonction
mais aussi l'importance de la relation
institutionnelle direct et forte qui
existe entre la MF et la représentation
nationale j'en suis pleinement
consciente et il est donc très important
que cette relation soit fondée sur la
confiance
si vous confirmez ma nomination j'aurais
évidemment l'occasion de revenir devant
vous pour rendre compte de l'action de
l'AMF qui entretient je le sais une
relation très étroite avec le Sénat mais
aussi sans doute pour évoquer des sujets
plus précis parmi vos préoccupations je
connais notamment l'attachement de votre
maison à la protection des épargnants
qui est la première mission de l'AMF
je vais tenter d'être synthétique dans
mes propos liminaires qui viseront
principalement à préciser la vision que
j'ai de la MF et ce qui dans mon
parcours a pu me préparer à élaborer
cette vision et à me donner les moyens
je l'espère de la mettre en œuvre je ne
reviendrai donc pas sur mon parcours qui
professionnellement a presque 30 ans
donc je pense que ça prendra un peu de
temps et puis ça n'est pas forcément
très passionnant sinon lorsqu'il pourra
venir étayer les convictions que je vais
essayer de vous présenter de manière
synthétique
fondamentalement à mes yeux le rôle du
président de l'AMF ou de sa présidence
et d'incarner l'institution
dans asseoir la puissance et la
crédibilité et d'exercer à bon escient
les pouvoirs qui sont les siens au
service d'objectifs clairs
il ne doit évidemment pas agir seul mais
avec son collège avec l'appui du
secrétariat général et avec les équipes
de la MF tous en sachant évidemment une
fine et assumer ses responsabilités
lorsque cela est nécessaire et utile
le président doit aussi prendre en
compte dans son action
rendre compte pardon de son action
d'abord au Parlement et il remet chaque
année par ailleurs un rapport au
président de la République au
gouvernement c'est non seulement
légitime mais c'est aussi nécessaire
pour agir à bon escient
enfin il doit développer le dialogue
avec la société civile au travers des
représentants des différentes parties
prenantes qui sont d'ores et déjà
aujourd'hui représentés à l'AMF
puisqu'elle dispose de plusieurs
commissions consultatives et d'un comité
scientifique mais aussi et c'est là une
nouveauté d'une certaine manière le
président ou la présidente doit trouver
le moyen de parler simplement et
efficacement à des publics un peu
nouveau particulièrement vulnérable
notamment les jeunes
il s'agit là d'une conviction profonde
non seulement tout citoyen doit avoir
accès à l'éducation financière car c'est
sans doute la meilleure des préventions
mais l'AMF doit poursuivre et adapter
ses efforts en matière de pédagogie et
de communication le rôle du président
tel que je le conçois sera de pousser le
plus loin possible l'accessibilité des
objectifs dont il a la charge à tout le
public concerné en effet la finance ne
doit jamais se satisfaire d'être un
monde d'expert or elle a parfois
tendance à s'y complaire se complaire
dans les sigles dans des termes
anglo-saxons qui laissent au bord de la
route la plupart d'entre nous y compris
moi d'ailleurs et ceux qui auraient le
plus besoin de comprendre ce dont il est
question
l'AMF doit continuer à être une boussole
un point de repère reconnu et crédible
elle doit en permanence définir des
points d'équilibre qui ne sont pas
toujours évidents entre plusieurs
objectifs qui peuvent apparaître
contradictoires au moins en apparence
l'innovation et la protection la
sécurité et le rendement
l'exhaustivité et la pertinence de
l'information et sa lisibilité la
compétitivité de la place financière et
la protection des épargnants et des
investisseurs
en tant qu'autorité de contrôle et
régulateur de marché l'AMF remplit un
rôle aussi traditionnel que fondamental
sur trois points la protection des
épargnants la transparence des marchés
et le financement de l'économie la
protection des épargnants je les dis est
le premier objectif tout simplement
parce que tout le monde n'est pas à
égalité face à l'information c'est en
soi donc un sujet majeur dans un univers
économique et financier qui est pour le
moins incertain au passage la MF peut
être amenée à gérer des crises situation
que j'ai été amenée à connaître à
plusieurs reprises évidemment je ne
souhaite pas forcément me retrouver une
quatrième fois face à une gestion de
crise mais après tout ce sont des choses
qui peut arriver et l'expérience peut
s'avérer un petit peu
utile deuxième objet objectif la
transparence des marchés nous disposons
d'instruments puissants mais encore
faut-il savoir où sont aujourd'hui les
marchés puisqu'il tout ne se passe pas
sur les marchés connus réglementés et
identifiés où se passent les
transactions ou se passe l'incitation à
investir c'est parfois aujourd'hui sur
les réseaux sociaux que ça se passe et
donc on est hors de l'univers classique
dans lequel nous intervenons troisième
objectif le financement de l'économie
qui nécessite également une vigilance
très particulière dans le contexte
actuel contexte marqué par un
endettement élevé des acteurs alors que
les taux d'intérêt remontent avec une
inflation élevée qui écrase un certain
nombre de rendements et donc peut créer
à la fois une
une recherche parfois dangereuse de
rendement sur des produits plus risqués
mais aussi peut amener à plus de courtes
hermismes et donc poser des problèmes
par rapport aux besoins de long terme
qui sont plus importants que jamais pour
financer nos infrastructures notre
modèle social ou évidemment la
transition écologique
au-delà de ces trois enjeux
traditionnels de l'AMF genre listerai
rapidement plusieurs qui sont assez
nouveaux pas tous totalement nouveaux
mais qui le sont par rapport à ces
missions traditionnelles d'abord le fait
que le riz les risques qui pèse sur
l'intégrité des marchés fait d'asymétrie
d'information et de frotte et arnaques
qui sont sans cesse renouvelés je pense
qu'il faut être conscient du fait que
le monde depuis que le monde est monde
on a toujours tenté d'arnaquer les gens
et que donc la question qui se pose à
nous aujourd'hui c'est comment est-ce
qu'on identifie au plus vite les
endroits où ça se passe et comment
est-ce qu'on agit efficacement
deuxième enjeu un peu nouveau les enjeux
liés aux données à la fois la protection
des données on voit d'ailleurs qu'il
peut y avoir une tension entre la
protection des données personnelles et
l'efficacité de la sanction des
régulateurs mais aussi la cybersécurité
l'innovation qu'il faut évidemment
comprendre encourager accompagner mais
aussi encadrer efficacement
l'objectif de verdissement de la finance
je parle de verdissement réel bien sûr
c'est un des grands objectifs dans
lequel l'AMF c'est beaucoup investi
depuis 2019 notamment
et elle le fait avec des outils
importants qui passent aussi d'ailleurs
par la réglementation européenne
les enjeux de l'égalité professionnelle
et de la diversité dans le monde
financier sont aussi des enjeux qu'ils
des enjeux n'ont pas nouveaux forcément
nouveaux mais que nous devons développer
pour que celle-ci reflète mieux la
société et encore une fois évitez qu'il
y ait des fuites vers d'autres univers
qui sont moins régulés le dernier enjeu
est sans doute le plus difficile c'est
d'obtenir la confiance des épargnants et
du grand public à l'heure des fake news
mais aussi de la décrédibilisation
généralisée des experts comment en tant
qu'expert prendre la parole être entendu
écouter ne pas être immédiatement
d'ailleurs démenti parce qu'on est
expert ou parce qu'on représente une
institution je n'ai pas forcément
d'ailleurs de réponse à ce sujet qui ne
concerne évidemment pas que l'AMF mais
il faut savoir que notre action devra
s'exercer dans ce contexte
donc l'AMF évidemment doit savoir
sanctionner lorsque c'est nécessaire ça
a aussi un aspect évidemment dissuasif
elle doit veiller à renforcer
constamment la sécurité juridique de son
action mais aussi la performance de ces
outils notamment ses outils numériques
c'est un sujet sur lequel il pourra
arriver d'ailleurs que l'AMF est besoin
de votre soutien
autre défi qui à mes yeux n'est pas le
moindre sans doute parce que j'y suis
particulièrement sensibilisée dans mes
fonctions actuelles de secrétaire
général d'un grand ministère l'AMF doit
disposer des moyens notamment humains de
mener à bien ses missions j'insiste sur
les moyens humains parce que bien sûr il
y a un jeu traditionnel sur les moyens
budgétaires je suis aujourd'hui un peu
en conflit d'intérêt puisque je suis
responsable financier du ministère de
l'économie et des finances mais je
plaide aussi la cause de l'AMF pour
autant je dirais que les enjeux
budgétaires bien sûr ils existent et il
ne faut pas le nier pour autant je pense
que le l'enjeu majeur c'est un enjeu
humain un enjeu de ressources humaines
c'est vraiment l'enseignement que je
tire des trois années que je viens de
consacrer à ces sujets au secrétariat
général du ministère
on peut se fixer un programme ambitieux
et adapté aux besoins des épargnants des
marchés et du financement de l'économie
si on n'a pas les équipes si on n'a pas
un dialogue social qui fonctionne et qui
permet d'arriver à des solutions et
parfois d'ailleurs à des compromis qui
seront solides plus que des choses que
l'on peut penser imposer sur le papier
franchement je pense qu'on n'arrivera
pas à grand chose et donc ça sera pour
moi un de mes principaux enjeux en tant
que présidente que de réfléchir et de
travailler à la mobilisation des équipes
à l'exemplarité interne aussi qui est
sans doute un des leviers les plus
puissants pour pour y parvenir notamment
quand on porte des combats forts
vis-à-vis du monde extérieur c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin aussi de de sentir qu'ils
sont portés en interne et dans la
gestion de la maison
au-delà de cette gestion interne je suis
convaincue que la MF doit accompagner la
place financière française et la tirer
vers le haut
permettez-moi d'évoquer là aussi une
conviction les meilleurs financiers sont
ceux qui savent qu'un gendarme sévère
mais juste et compétent bien sûr est à
terme la meilleure garantie de pérennité
et de développement d'une place
financière c'est en tout cas le choix
qui a été fait sur une place
continentale comme Paris et je pense
qu'il nous appartient la MF d'ailleurs
de convaincre ceux qui n'y croient pas
ou qui n'ont pas compris donc nous avons
les moyens de le faire et d'autre part
de d'imposer ce choix stratégique qui
est un choix de moyens et long terme
c'est d'autant plus important que le
brexit a ouvert de réelles opportunités
de développer cette activité non pas
uniquement pour elle-même d'ailleurs
même s'il y a à la clé quelques emplois
directs et indirects mais surtout pour
s'assurer que nous avons en France les
moyens de drainer notre épargne qui est
abondante vers le financement de nos
acteurs prioritairement et d'assurer
ainsi l'attractivité et la soutenabilité
de notre économie ainsi que la
localisation des centres de décision sur
notre territoire et une fine et notre
souveraineté
mais cette attractivité évidemment ne
peut pas se faire au détriment de
l'intégrité nous sommes confrontés à une
tentation réelle ou supposée de
compétitions réglementaires avec un
risque de compétition vers le moins 10
ans réglementaire il m'est arrivé dans
le passé d'entendre des propos en
provenance de telle ou tel représentants
de place financières qui faisait du
moins 10 ans réglementaire un argument
de vente j'ai expliqué en quoi je n'y
croyais pas et aussi en quoi nous
pouvons faire prévaloir c'est une
approche de long terme protectrice
soucieuse d'intégrité
et qui nous permet d'ailleurs d'être aux
avant-postes en matière de finances
verte
je terminerai donc je l'ai un peu abordé
par l'importance de la crédibilité de
l'AMF en Europe et à l'international
c'est évidemment fondamental pour peser
dans ses batailles réglementaires dont
j'ai appris à comprendre les enjeux
concurrentiels il arrive en effet
notamment que derrière une virgule une
phrase manquante dans une directive
européenne on favorise où on défavorise
telle ou tel modèle économique et
financier donc ça nécessite une grande
vigilance et il faut non seulement
savoir lire entre les lignes mais aussi
se battre avec des armes qui ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes que celles
auxquelles nous sommes habitués sur
notre territoire
l'AMF dispose d'une grande crédibilité
aujourd'hui dans les sénacles européens
et internationaux elle le doit largement
à Robert hoffel qui a su
renforcer considérablement le poids de
la parole de la MF en Europe et au
niveau international
ce qui n'est pas d'ailleurs si facile
que ça puisqu'on est dans un univers qui
reste aujourd'hui encore largement
dominé par le monde anglo-saxon mais il
s'agit d'un atout clé que j'aurais à
cœur de maintenir et de développer alors
évidemment ça ne se décrète pas je l'ai
d'ailleurs un peu vécu au cours des
années que j'ai passé sur les sujets
européens européens et notamment à
Bruxelles la crédibilité vis-à-vis de
nos interlocuteurs elle s'acquiert avec
le temps avec la fiabilité avec la
transparence avec l'attention que l'on
apporte
à la compréhension de leurs enjeux à la
capacité à négocier des compromis ça
passe aussi par l'affirmation simple et
souvent directe de ce qui est important
pour nous de ce qui n'est pas négociable
et de nos spécificités évidemment ça
nécessite de devoir à la fois renoncer à
avoir raison tout seul qui est un peu un
travers auquel nous sommes parfois je
l'espère à tort enclin du point de vue
de nos partenaires
et ça n'est donc pas toujours facile
mais ça ne veut pas dire pour autant
qu'on ne doit pas défendre nos objectifs
sans présupposer évidemment qu'ils sont
compris connus voire même partager je
veillerai évidemment à travailler en ce
sens et monsieur le Président je vous
remercie de votre attention ainsi que
les membres de la commission et le
rapporteur
merci Madame pour ce propos introductif
très clair qui marque votre vision et
les lignes directrices qui seraient les
vôtres si vous êtes désigné à la tête de
la MF et sans plus attendre je vais
passer la parole à notre apporteur qui
est désigné pour cette audition albéric
de Montgolfier merci monsieur le
Président Madame Mercier de ses propos
qui sur votre parcours et votre vision
qui est répond déjà à un certain nombre
de questions
je vais commencer par revenir un peu sur
votre parcours non pas qu'il pose des
difficultés vous avez une expérience qui
est à la fois dans le secteur privé à la
Fédération
Crédit Agricole dans le secteur public
notamment à travers la supervision des
marchés dans les différents bureaux de
trésor et également c'est là où certains
nombre d'entre nous vous ont connu entre
2014 et 2019 à la Direction Générale de
la Fédération Bancaire Française donc
une expérience qui est riche qui à mon
sens vous qualifie pour ce poste mais il
y a une question qui va nécessairement
se poser qui peut se poser
qui est celle du des éventuels conflits
d'intérêts puisque vous avez par exemple
lorsqu'on est à la Fédération bancaire
française on a qu'à mettre dans le
cutter des régulateurs on a parfois
contre soi ou un dialogue avec la CPA
par exemple et il fera rappeler que les
normes professionnelles
des établissements qui sont membres de
la Fédération bancaire française sont
également parfois définis pour partir
par l'AMF par le biais de ce règlement
général donc la question qui se pose est
très simple comment pensez-vous réponse
à cette question cette situation de prêt
pour prévenir les conflits d'intérêt
est-ce que vous semble que la
collégialité c'est sans doute une
réponse est-elle suffisante alors que le
président ou la présidente de l'AMF
dispose de pouvoir d'une autorité
particulière et ce que vous estimez que
la composition par exemple du collège de
la MF devait être revu pour équilibrer
les intérêts repentant voilà je pense
qu'il y a besoin d'éclaircissement même
si encore une fois on échangé avec vous
j'ai changé nous avons échanger ce
week-end après la base de cette édition
c'est toujours un sujet
par définition
extrêmement compliqué on nous demande de
désigner des personnalités qualifiées
mais il faudrait par définition qu'elle
jamais eu d'intérêt donc voilà c'était
pas des sur impossible donc pour moi
c'est pas en soi l'expérience est
quelque chose de nécessaire et vraiment
votre expérience de ce point de vue vous
qualifie il faut juste peut-être avoir
cette réponse sur les éléments qui
permettraient éventuellement de prévenir
s'il devait y avoir des conflits
d'intérêt j'ai trois questions sur le
fond puisqu'on va demander de préparer
cette audition
la première vous l'avez un peu abordé
dans votre propos préliminaire il
concerne le contexte que nous vivons
actuellement
contexte d'inflation
volatilité forte sur les marchés
turbulents sur les marchés qui conduit
un certain nombre d'épargnants qui
conduit un grand épargnants se tournait
vers parfois des produits plus exotiques
ou être sous l'influence parfois des
informations sur Internet voir
d'influenceurs il a des condamnations à
ces dégâts et donc et parfois aller vers
des actifs qui sont très peu réguliers
je pense aux crypto actifs très
volatiles donc la question dans ce
contexte de d'inflation de Cortex de
volatilité des marchés comment mieux
protéger les épargnants vous avez que
c'est une préoccupation vous l'avez dit
du Sénat de j'ai porté moi même un
certain nombre d'amendements qui sont
dans la loi maintenant pour interdire la
publicité sur certains produits exotique
comment donc protéger mieux les
épargnants qui pourraient être tentés
d'aller des produits plus risqués mais
qui n'en maîtrisent pas forcément le
fonctionnement comment transmettre les
bonnes informations
et si votre nomination à la tête de la f
était approuvée globalement quel point
d'équilibre faut-il trouver entre
l'innovation que nécessaire on va pas
rester figé sur des produits sinon c'est
la compétitivité la place de Paris qui
peut s'en trouver moins de riz et donc
il faut assurer cette innovation mais
également cette protection qui va vous
l'avez dit votre propos préliminaire la
mission première de l'AMF et de ce point
de vue également comment mieux
normaliser l'information on a fait des
avec le rapporteur général la somme de
proposition en matière d'assurance vie
sur les frais
les épanouiants ils sont noyés vous
l'avez dit sur un cas flow
d'informations sur Internet
il est parfois difficile de trouver une
information fiable et normalisée donc
c'est une première question protection
information des épargnants dans un
contexte de fortes volatilité des
marchés et de fortes turbulences
la deuxième question concerne ce que
nous avons fréquemment abordé ces
dernières années dans cette commission
les conséquences du brexit sur la
régulation des marchés financiers alors
vous l'avez dit au Royaume-Uni le
gouvernement et vend du masculin reste
et le régulateur britannique annonce
régulièrement vouloir simplifier alléger
les normes et les règles qui pèsent sur
la physique sur les City alors ma
question est très simple qui est selon
vous le bon dosage entre protection des
épargnants mission première vous l'avez
dit et recherche de la compétitivité
pour la place de Paris alors par le
passé vous avez dit je crois je vous
cite qu'il faut pas avoir face à
l'argumentation qu'il faut avoir une
approche non naïve de l'impact des
normes sur les acteurs donc est-ce que
vous pouvez développer sur ce point ce
qui n'approche qu'on à Yves et notamment
comment envisagez-vous l'articulation
entre
la supervision la supervision nationale
celle de la et l'Autorité européenne de
régulation des marchés et troisième et
dernière question elle porte sur les
décisions de justice de justice récente
y compris de la Cour de justice qui ont
annulé un certain nombre de décisions
notamment les fadettes sur les droits de
visite et qui conduisent de fait à
réduire considérablement les pouvoirs
d'enquête de l'AMF notamment je pense au
délit d'initié voilà donc si demain on
peut plus enquêter si on peut plus
conserver les traces est-ce que ça sert
encore quelque chose d'avoir un comité
de sanction comme mission de sanctions
ou alors est-ce que c'est la porte
ouverte à tous les délits et y compris
délit d'initier donc quel est votre
position c'est très compliqué parce que
ça dépend pas simplement des
juridictions nationales faut-il faire
évoluer la réglementation j'aimerais
vous entendre sur ce point donc merci
pour ces propos introductifs et on sera
très heureux de vous entendre
merci monsieur le rapporteur et je vous
propose un de répondre tout de suite
à l'intervention et aux questions de
notre apporteur avant de procéder autour
de table habituelles
merci
président la première question qui a été
posée par monsieur le rapporteur est
évidemment fondamental c'est la question
de mon parcours qui je ne suis pas naïve
justement je ne méconnais pas le fait
qu'il peut interroger même s'il n'a rien
non plus de particulièrement je dirais
original puisque
j'ai je vais aborder l'année prochaine
je pense ma 30e année de carrière j'ai
dû consacrer à plus de 20 ans au secteur
public effectivement au fond si je
devais caractériser
mon parcours est-ce qu'il y a le plus
compté c'est quand même la régulation et
notamment la direction du Trésor et
l'inspection générale des finances où
j'ai j'ai eu l'occasion de travailler je
pense le plus longtemps mais
effectivement j'ai travaillé dans le
secteur privé
cela me donne je pense une une
expérience et une compétence qui seront
utiles pour expertiser voir contre
expertiser dans un certain nombre de le
cas les éléments qui pourront être
avancés par un certain nombre
d'interlocuteurs
depuis son origine d'ailleurs l'AMF et
ses deux ancêtres lacob et le CMF ont
toujours trouvé l'occasion d'avoir un
dialogue avec le secteur privé ce qui ne
veut pas dire d'ailleurs que le
règlement général de l'AMF ça ne m'a
jamais été présenté comme tel a été
écrit par quiconque d'autres que l'AMF
et donc je pense que c'est ça en fait le
le point majeur c'est avec son
expérience avec son intégrité
personnelle avec sa vision des choses
de prendre la bonne distance par rapport
à un secteur régulé mais qu'il faut
aussi comprendre et connaître une
régulation ne peut fonctionner que si
elle intervient au bon endroit à bon
escient en tenant compte des contraintes
ne serait-ce que technique qui peuvent
se poser par exemple sur les systèmes
d'information au-delà de ça il y a la
question des éventuelles conflits
d'intérêts alors as au jour où parle je
suis juridiquement concerné par un
conflit d'intérêt direct qui est le fait
que j'exerce actuellement encore un
mandat pour le compte de l'État dans la
banque Dexia enfin ce qu'il en reste et
donc bon fondament alors là évidemment
un si je suis je suis retenu pour ce
poste démissionnerait évidemment de ce
mandat et d'autre part cela signifie en
effet que si Dexia est amené à venir
poser des questions à la MF là et c'est
un cas clair de déport absolu c'est à
dire que je ne pourrai pas me prononcer
ensuite il y a une question qui est plus
compliquée qui est au-delà des conflits
d'intérêts directs manifestent prévu par
la loi
la question de ce qu'on appelle parfois
la théorie des apparences c'est à dire
comment faire en sorte que effectivement
les décisions qui seront prises par la
MF ne puissent pas être considéré comme
ayant été totalement influencé par
certains des éléments de mon parcours
professionnel bon là je dirais qu'il y a
plusieurs réponses vous l'avez évoqué
monsieur le rapporteur l'AMF est
fondamentalement une institution
collégiale pour avoir beaucoup travaillé
dans des autorités de contrôle puisque
j'ai siégé pendant je pense 7 ans dans
l'ancêtre de la CPR qui s'appelle à
l'époque encore la Commission bancaire
il y avait le CEEI d'ailleurs aussi
et bien la façon dont ça se passe c'est
que déjà les décisions sont préparées
par des services donc ce n'est pas moi
toute seule qui évidemment veut élaborer
dans le secret de mon bureau une
décision qui pourrait être ensuite
critiquable ensuite et c'est fondamental
ça c'est une expérience que j'ai eu à
plusieurs reprises dans ma carrière on
travaille de manière collégiale alors
certes il y a des pouvoirs propres du
président et c'est sans doute là qu'il
faudra que je sois le plus vigilante
c'est-à-dire lorsqu'on est dans des
pouvoirs propres du président par
rapport par exemple faire appel d'une
décision de la commission des sanctions
qui est complètement indépendante au
sein de la MF alors à ce moment là
effectivement la question devra c'est là
où le l'intensité de la question de
l'apparence de conflit d'intérêt pourra
se poser au maximum mais le reste du
temps évidemment il y a un collège
d'après ce que je peux savoir d'ailleurs
au collège le début de des PV c'est
toujours
l'identification des conflits d'intérêts
potentiels des membres du collège y
compris son Président ou sa présidente
donc là d'abord la collégialité ça
permet effectivement de d'éviter de
prendre des décisions inadaptées d'une
manière générale et qui pourrait
effectivement poser problème il faut que
le dialogue soit franc au sein du
collège si quelques personnes autour de
la table du collège me dit bah là-dessus
madame la Présidente on pense que votre
intervention pourrait être mal
interprété
on se s'organisera d'ailleurs il y a un
des membres du collège qui je crois le
la personne qui a été désignée par le
Conseil d'État qui est en charge de la
déontologie au sein du collège et qui
pourra intervenir sur ces sujets donc
voilà ce que je peux apporter comme
réponse il y a évidemment des réponses
juridiques clairs j'ai indiqué qu'elles
étaient de mon point de vue les conflits
directs que je pouvais
identifier il y a une réponse plus je
dirais de pratique de de d'attention
apporter à aux décisions de
l'institution qui doivent être
évidemment incontestable et je crois
avoir essayé de d'indiquer que ça serait
effectivement une question de pratique
de mise en oeuvre et de prévention et
aussi de de bonnes perceptions et de
dialogue avec le déontologue par exemple
du collège
vous avez évoqué trois questions de fond
alors la question d'abord du du contexte
sur les marchés et d'une forme de
notamment l'inflation la volatilité qui
peuvent évidemment amener les épargnants
à prendre des décisions
peu avisées en se tournant en soi vers
ce que vous appelez des produits
exotiques soit en écoutant davantage les
influenceurs que l'AMF qui est un sujet
qui dépasse le contexte actuel
malheureusement ou en allant investir
dans des produits risqués type crypto
actifs et donc la question c'est comment
mieux protéger les épargnants dans ce
contexte sans pour autant vous avez
aussi évoqué ce point tu es l'innovation
puisque effectivement on peut avoir la
tentation de se dire ouh là là tout ça
est très compliqué et donc on ne fait
rien on n'en veut pas chez nous et là
effectivement la place de Paris pourrait
être en effet en retard
vous avez évoqué une autre question
enfin une question qui est liée
d'ailleurs qui est comment mieux
normaliser l'information puisque
effectivement il y a une tension
permanente entre une information
exhaustive et une information qui est
lue et qui est comprise donc ça c'est
effectivement un point important donc
d'abord comment protéger les épargnants
dans le contexte actuel
il y a une gradation de choses que l'on
peut faire d'abord effectivement
lorsqu'on est face à des produits qui
sont véritablement trop dangereux ça a
été le cas des options binaires ça a été
le cas du trading sur le Forex etc il
faut tout simplement interdire après il
y a des sujets plus qui sont un peu au
milieu du gué je dirais qui est par
exemple le sujet des crypto actifs alors
je dois dire que je suis très admirative
de l'approche qui a été retenue par la
MF puisque l'AMF a décidé elle était
seule à l'époque à le faire même si
aujourd'hui il y a un règlement européen
et qui est largement qui a été largement
initié suite à l'initiative française
l'AMF a été la première à introduire une
forme de réglementation avec un
dispositif d'enregistrement et
d'agrément pour les prestataires de
crypto actifs il y avait là une forme de
Paris Sana d'ailleurs pas forcément été
très comment dire unanimement accueillie
à l'époque parce que comme dans toute
prise de risque effectivement il y a il
y a un risque et je pense que ce risque
était cette prise de risque était
justifiée
parce que de toute façon ces activités
se déroulaient donc soit on considérait
que on n'était pas concernés que les
gens qui mettent de l'argent dans les
crypto actifs et ce sont souvent des
jeunes
un peu moins aguerri que de plus anciens
dirons-nous et qui ne se
s'identifie peut-être même pas eux-mêmes
comme épargnant et pouvant bénéficier
d'une protection quelconque donc en
prenant cette cette initiative de dire
ce sont des actifs financiers
comme d'autres ou en tout cas
qui peuvent être assimilés à d'autres
actifs financiers donc les opérateurs
qui veulent intervenir sur notre
territoire doivent être enregistrés
voire agréer alors je crois qu'il n'y a
pas eu de cas d'agrément jusqu'à présent
mais ça sera sans doute une des choses
qui sera ouverte avec le nouveau
règlement sur les crypto actifs
européens qui qui va entrer en vigueur
mais il y a eu des entités qui ont été
enregistrées et d'ailleurs l'une d'entre
elles vient d'être vient de se voir
retirer son enregistrement ce qui montre
d'ailleurs l'intérêt de cette démarche
parce que je pense que le fait de se
voir retirer l'enregistrement à
certainement un effet de
contre-publicité je pense que c'était
une des choses qui étaient recherchée
par la MF justement de pouvoir
intervenir en termes de communication
aussi sur la base de cette action
deuxième question effectivement les
influenceurs alors il n'y a pas
évidemment de réglementation du métré
métier d'influenceurs à moins qu'ils
n'ont puisse rentrer dans la
qualification de conseiller
en investissement ce qui n'est
évidemment pas le cas parce que la
plupart d'entre eux parlent de tout un
tas de sujets et au passage
effectivement souvent moyennant finance
et là c'est là qu'on a un biais pour
intervenir en partenariat avec la DGCCRF
d'ailleurs au passage et bien ils font
de la publicité pour des produits
financiers sans le dire et sans dire
qu'ils sont rémunérés pour cela donc la
première chose à faire c'est d'essayer
de faire progresser la transparence
ça ça passe évidemment par l'action qui
a été engagée d'ailleurs avec l'Autorité
de régulation de la publicité et ça peut
aussi passer par l'exercice d'un pouvoir
de sanction alors qu'il n'appartient pas
à l'AMF mais qui peut se faire en
mobilisant la DGCCRF il y a d'ailleurs
déjà un précédent
et c'est d'ailleurs un sujet que j'ai
déjà pu évoquer avec mon actuel collègue
qui dirige la DGCCRF et qui m'a rappelé
qu'il serait utile que nous refassions
une convention un protocole entre la
DGCCRF et l'AMF ce à quoi je
m'attacherai je me demande aussi s'il
serait pas utile d'aller collaborer un
peu plus directement avec l'autorité
nationale des jeux non pas qu'on soit
exactement dans le même domaine mais il
y a parfois des comment dire des
modalités de publicité ou de ou de
diffusion effectivement qui peuvent être
proches donc ça m'intéressera d'avoir
effectivement leur leur
connaissance de ce sujet après je pense
qu'il faut se dire que
[Musique]
à l'âge qui est le mien je n'ai
peut-être pas exactement tous les outils
pour
identifier les modalités dont sur
lesquelles interviennent les
influenceurs donc ça veut peut-être dire
qu'il faut qu'on s'aide joigne au sein
de la commission scientifique ou au sein
des comités consultatifs de l'AMF des
experts qui connaissent un tout petit
peu mieux les réseaux sociaux ce qui s'y
passe et le monde des influenceurs qui
est effectivement
assez peu réguler pour ce que je peux en
voir
vous avez donc sur l'information alors
effectivement
on a des prospectus qui sont je pense
assez exhaustif
voire trop la question c'est
effectivement alors il y a eu sur
beaucoup de produits à la fiche
d'information synthétique simplifiée qui
a été mise en place au niveau européen
et donc effectivement c'est tout un art
d'exécution là aussi puisque d'une part
s'il y a plein de choses dans le
prospectus et sans doute parce que ces
choses sont utiles et après il faut en
faire une synthèse parce qu'autrement
personne mise à part les investisseurs
ultra avisés ou qui peuvent payer des
gens qui savent lire les prospectus ne
peuvent les utiliser à bon escient donc
oui c'est un vrai sujet
il y a déjà des tentatives et des et des
manières de essayer de justement d'avoir
des fiches synthétiques qui sont
lisibles et qui sont qui sont
accessibles plus accessibles aux
investisseurs particuliers notamment
après il faut peut-être là aussi aller
chercher du côté des sciences
comportementales pour justement mieux
identifier comment est-ce qu'on
communique efficacement comment est-ce
que en une phrase on dit que par exemple
il y a pas de rendement sans risque et
enfin quelques sujets de base que qui
sont un peu perdus de vue
malheureusement c'est aussi le sujet de
l'éducation financière que j'évoquais
d'ailleurs les institutions publiques
notamment la Banque de France ils sont
beaucoup ont beaucoup monté en puissance
dans ce domaine je pense qu'il est
il est important que tous les Français
puissent avoir un minimum de bagages sur
ces sujets même quand ils n'ont pas
beaucoup d'argent et je dirais a
fortiori quand ils n'ont pas beaucoup
d'argent ils peuvent pas se permettre de
tout perdre et donc c'est là qu'il faut
aller les chercher au bon endroit sans
doute dans le système scolaire et puis
ensuite à d'autres endroits d'ailleurs
peut-être en utilisant nous-même les
canaux de l'influence après tout
visiblement ça marche dans d'autres
domaines donc il faut peut-être se poser
ce type de questions et progresser sur
effectivement les différents canaux de
communication qu'on peut utiliser
vous avez posé la question des
conséquences du brexit sur la régulation
des marchés financiers avec
effectivement le risque je parle bien de
risques parce que je pense qu'on ne peut
pas avoir de soupçons a priori qu'il y
ait une compétition et basée sur le
moins 10 ans réglementaire alors ça
c'est une réalité il faut là aussi
savoir utiliser sa puissance l'Europe
est un énorme marché l'Union européenne
est un énorme marché notamment parce que
l'épargne est extrêmement abondante et
c'est quand même la matière première sur
laquelle travaille les marchés
financiers et donc il faut que nous
soyons vigilants notamment dans toutes
les discussions qui vont avoir lieu
maintenant alors qu'ils peuvent être
d'apparence effectivement très technique
sur les équivalences c'est à dire est-ce
que au moment où le Royaume-Uni
puisqu'on parle du Royaume-Uni a quitté
l'Union européenne par définition ils
avaient les mêmes textes que nous
puisque on était dans un univers
d'harmonisation
alors après il y a la mise en oeuvre de
la réglementation qui est aussi un autre
sujet mais en tout cas ils avaient les
mêmes textes que nous et donc parfois il
râlait contre ces textes d'ailleurs
notamment je me souviens d'une croisade
contre les le plafonnement des
rémunérations sur les marchés financiers
mais ils avaient je crois été jusqu'à la
Cour de justice qui leur avait indiqué
qu'il devait respecter cette
réglementation donc je ne soupçonne pas
du tout a priori la place financière de
Londres qui est une des trois plus
grandes places financières mondiale de
vouloir prendre des risques excessifs et
de se retrouver dans des situations qui
ont pu être connues par d'autres places
financières avec des défauts d'intégrité
des canaux de financement
reposant sur du blanchiment voire du
financement du terrorisme c'est
évidemment pas l'intérêt d'une place
financière et je pense que la place
financière de Londres en est pleinement
consciente après il faut regarder parce
que le diable peut être dans les détails
effectivement c'est à dire est-ce que on
est sur de la stricte équivalence
c'est-à-dire est-ce que
les réglementation qui désormais est
autonome au Royaume-Uni va être
totalement calé sur la réglementation
européenne
la Cour de justice je crois n'aura plus
l'occasion de de trancher ces les
différents éventuels sur la mise en
oeuvre de la réglementation donc voilà
il faudra effectivement être présent
auprès de la Commission européenne qui
devra instruire les dossiers de demande
d'équivalence et s'assurer qu'il n'y a
pas en effet de distorsion de
concurrence liées à une phrase manquante
comme je le disais tout à l'heure ou à
une virgule
voire une traduction qu'on a pu le voir
dans certains domaines quand j'étais
attaché financier à Bruxelles
j'assistais à toutes les réunions des
traducteurs parce que effectivement
souvent au la traduction pouvait avoir
disons des des nuances voilà et donc les
nuances peuvent parfois être très
problématiques et il faut être vigilant
et se faire confiance se dire
qu'effectivement nous représentons
un marché important l'Europe représente
un marché important et elle doit pouvoir
affirmer son objectif par définition
depuis l'origine la réglementation
financière européenne elle est
particulièrement protectrice et sa
marque de fabrique elle est d'ailleurs
en partie liée à la philosophie
française en la matière qui est
peut-être un peu plus protectrice que
d'autres dans beaucoup de domaines y
compris dans le domaine financier donc
je pense qu'il faut être très vigilant
évidemment ça passe par le travail à
lesma c'est clair ça passe aussi par le
travail dans les dans les institutions
internationales il y a une réunion en ce
moment même de l'iosco au Maroc ou je
pense que ces sujets vont être débattus
puisque
effectivement il y a des questions
d'équivalence pour accéder de notre
marché ou tout simplement de protection
pour les investisseurs qui pourraient
être confrontés à des acteurs qui ne
seraient pas un minima enregistré sur le
marché européen
sur les décisions de justice récente bon
par définition elles sont légitimes
par définition après il va falloir
effectivement que l'AMF je pense que
c'est presque un peu tôt pour pour le
dire examine exactement les conséquences
de ces décisions de justice je pense
notamment à la décision de justice
à la vie qui a été demandé à la Cour de
justice européenne à la vie
préjudiciaire sur la conservation et
l'utilisation des fadettes sujet qui
d'ailleurs ne concerne pas que la MF
alors c'est particulièrement important
pour l'AMF parce que je crois que la
jurisprudence à ce stade qui avait déjà
été par le Conseil d'État au niveau
français etc indique que la conservation
de ces fadettes de manière un peu
indifférenciée elle est possible mais
quand on est face à un délit pénal grave
donc évidemment
ça ne couvre pas absolument tout ce que
l'AMF pourrait vouloir sanctionner donc
il va falloir réexaminer effectivement
comment est-ce qu'on préserve nos
pouvoirs d'enquête comment est-ce qu'on
fait peut-être un peu plus de visite
domiciliaire puisque ça n'est pas
contesté et aussi comment est-ce
qu'effectivement le cas échéant on
sollicite des adaptations
réglementaires ou législatives si tenter
d'ailleurs qu'on ait une marge de
manœuvre au niveau franco-français
puisque il y a un avis de la Cour de
justice après les avis de la Cour de
justice il faut les interpréter et voir
jusqu'où effectivement on peut préserver
l'équilibre qui avait été trouvé par les
juridictions françaises mais c'est
effectivement un sujet de préoccupation
parce que si on n'a pas les moyens de
faire de faire des enquêtes et de
sanctionner correctement on a moins de
pouvoir de dissuasion notamment parce
que évidemment on ne peut pas forcément
identifier tous les problèmes toutes les
enquêtes mais chaque fois qu'il y a des
sanctions c'est évidemment très
dissuasifs si on n'arrive plus à
sanctionner là j'avoue que effectivement
il y a un problème mais enfin je pense
pas qu'on en soit là et ça sera
certainement un des dossiers que je
j'ouvrirai prioritairement lorsque je
j'aurai l'occasion de le faire
bien merci après toutes ces réponses
très très complètes à notre à notre
apporteur je vous propose de céder la
parole au collègues et en premier lieu à
Hervé Moret
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame secrétaire général merci de votre
intervention et des éléments que vous
nous avez apporté je voudrais vous dire
que naturellement je ne doute pas un
seul instant de vos compétences mais je
suis plus inquiet sur la question de
l'indépendance vous avez répondu sur la
question du conflit d'intérêt ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose que
le conflit d'intérêt peut avoir un une
connotation juridique et pénale que n'a
pas l'indépendance pour autant
l'indépendance pour une autorité
administrative indépendante c'est tout à
fait essentiel et personnellement je
suis très attaché à l'indépendance
réelle des autorités administratives
indépendantes qui ne peuvent être
indépendantes que si le président ou la
présidente est réellement indépendante
or vous arrivez ceux qui ont soif n'est
pas péché mais peut-être problématique
directement de Bercy vous arriveriez
directement de Bercy donc quel
indépendance par rapport à l'État et
vous avez comme vous l'avez mentionné
comme ça a été rappelé exercer un
certain temps des responsabilités
importantes au sein de la fédération
française de banque donc dans ces
conditions comment pouvez-vous vraiment
nous assurer que il y aura d'autres
parts une indépendance qui est
indispensable par rapport à la mission
première vous l'avez rappelé de de
l'autorité qui est la protection de
l'épargne
merci Jérôme Bacher
merci monsieur le Président secrétaire
général c'est toujours une gageure de
faire un discours politique général avec
à la fin à votre de confiance ou une
destitution mais plus sérieusement vous
avez parlé de verdissement de la finance
un mot une phrase en disant que c'est un
sujet important notamment en termes de
normalisation est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire dans quel sens vous voulez aller
plutôt dans le sens je veux dire
proposé par lesma ou plutôt l'Union
européenne enfin j'aimerais bien avoir
un peu votre tendance par rapport à
votre prédécesseur qui s'était fortement
impliqué dans l'affaire
et d'autre part ils avaient commencé à y
répondre avec les questions de d'Albéric
de Montgolfier
c'est quoi la prochaine crise
parce qu'effectivement quand vous êtes
dans un sujet de volatilité et que vous
êtes dans un sujet d'inflation on vient
de le voir il y a 15 jours en Angleterre
je suis pas sûr que vous désyez
aujourd'hui soit les éléments à
l'Autorité des marchés financiers c'est
quoi votre je veux dire votre vigilance
là du moment
mettons vous êtes déjà en poste et tout
ce qu'on vous souhaite mais c'est quoi
votre vigilance toute particulière sur
ces marchés aujourd'hui
merci on poursuit le tour de table avec
Didier Rambaud merci Président Madame
loscargira alors c'est vrai que quand je
me suis inscrit c'était pour vous
interroger sur la réglementation des
crypto monnaie bon vous avez en partie
répondu aux interrogations de la mairie
de Montgolfier néanmoins comme le sujet
fait quand même l'objet de je dirais de
nombreux fantasmes je constate
qu'effectivement qu'il attire les jeunes
alors j'aimerais que vous précisiez un
peu plus notamment sur cette cette
réglementation des crypto monnaies et la
réglementation européenne est-ce que
pour vous elle est voilà quel est votre
avis elle est suffisante il faut qu'on
avance sur ce sujet là
voilà c'est un sujet qui qui interprète
beaucoup merci
merci Christine
merci monsieur le Président alors
également vous avez vite fait évoqué en
répondant aux rapporteur le fait que
vous seriez conduite à discuter avec
d'autres autorités de régulation j'ai
compris qu'ils devaient s'agir de largel
et justement je souhaitais vous
intéresser sur ce sujet puisqu'on voit
bien que aujourd'hui
l'argent se déplace et dans de nouveaux
secteurs notamment celui des jeux de
hasard et le rapporteur voilà insistait
aussi sur la nécessité de ne pas brider
l'innovation mais on sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui avec la licorne Sora des
vraies questions se posent et notamment
comment aller voir arriver à te fixer la
ligne entre ce qui est le jeu ce qui est
l'argent et les marchés financiers et
donc avez-vous des pistes d'évolution
merci Marc lamelie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
reporter merci madame la secrétaire
général pour votre exposé et puis aussi
concernant votre parcours antérieur qui
est tout à fait remarquable alors moi
j'aurais deux trois interrogations parce
que
bon les personnes avertis je reste nous
restons très modeste
qui connaît la MF
donc on parle de MF je fais toujours le
lien avec les collectivités locales
l'Association des maires de France
et
la MF autorité des marchés financiers
quand on évoque j'irai dans l'opinion
publique à mon avis il y a pas grand
monde qui qui s'est tout à fait alors
vous avez insisté sur les moyens humains
sur la bonne communication
et puis en termes de gouvernance comment
ça peut s'articuler parce
un certain nombre de personnes qui
travaillent et puis vous avez insisté
aussi gros sur la notion de proximité
parce qu'on est tout et tous attaché à
la notion de proximité puis là
centralisation c'est toujours Paris ou
la région parisienne et puis il ne faut
pas ou oublier
l'ensemble des territoires en
particulier les territoires ruraux dont
les Ardennes oui voilà merci merci
Albéric et quel est aussi le lien
entre
l'Autorité des marchés financiers et les
collectivités territoriales parce que
bon on s'aperçoit que bon même si les
collectivités locales investissent mais
elles ont quand même toujours du mal à
obtenir à obtenir des prêts des
organismes bancaires voilà mes modestes
questions je vous remercie sincèrement
merci Marc et pour clore ce tour de
table il y a d'autres inscriptions
d'accord alors en tous les cas c'est le
tour de 25 apocanella merci monsieur le
Président Madame le secrétaire général
je vais rejoindre la question de Jérôme
bachel tout à l'heure parce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure vous avez vécu
trois crises alors question c'est
quelles leçons vous en tirer pour l'AMF
singulièrement aujourd'hui quel devrait
être le rôle de l'AMF dans la période
que nous vivons notamment sur les
marchés et puis d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous utiliseriez ce mot de crise pour
qualifier la situation actuelle deuxième
point tout à l'heure s'agissant des
crypto monnaie j'ai compris que vous
parliez de partenariat avec la DGCCRF
alors il y a une convention avec le
ministère mais est-ce que vous pouvez
nous peut-être préciser parce que
la MEF est indépendante comment ce
partenariat peut vivre et juridiquement
comment chacun joue bien son rôle en
toute indépendance
merci Madame paoligajen
oui merci beaucoup
j'aurais voulu savoir madame par rapport
à la position de l'AMF qui était très
critique envers le cadre européen de la
finance durable en Europe si on va
pouvoir aller plus loin en fait que la
publication d'une simple méthodologie et
si vous avez comme perspective d'y
travailler ardemment merci
merci pas d'autres questions donc
écoutez vous appartient de
il vous appartiennent d'apporter des
réponses à ces questions précises qui
ont été posées merci
donc je vais commencer par par répondre
à monsieur le sénateur Hervé Moré qui a
posé la question de l'indépendance qui
est une question effectivement
plus vaste en effet que le la question
de des conflits d'intérêt indépendance
qui se pose pour une autorité
indépendante à la fois
vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis de du secteur régulé
évidemment mais aussi vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et donc de ce point de vue
là si je peux me permettre aussi au
passage de reparler de la question de
mon parcours et des interrogations
qu'elle peut qu'il peut susciter je
dirais que de toute façon personne ne
naît présidente d'une autorité
administrative indépendante donc
forcément c'est quelque chose qui arrive
à un moment de son parcours
professionnel d'abord parce qu'on a
acquis la conviction qu'on disposait
au fond de soi de cette capacité
effectivement à exercer une fonction
indépendante il se trouve comme je l'ai
évoqué d'ailleurs que j'ai été amené
beaucoup plus il y a beaucoup plus
longtemps et beaucoup plus tôt dans ma
carrière assiégé au sein d'une autorité
de contrôle donc d'une autorité
indépendante même si je ne suis plus
précieux que juridiquement elle n'est
pas un statut très Haddock qui était
l'ancêtre de l'actuel acpl donc
j'y représenté l'état donc évidemment
dans une position spécifique de
commissaire du gouvernement dont je
mesure évidemment toute la distinction
par rapport à ce rôle que j'aurais
maintenant et justement j'ai bien vu
qu'elle était la spécificité de du
travail collégial au sein d'une autorité
de ce type là par rapport effectivement
à l'intervention éventuelle du
commissaire du gouvernement qui peut
être comme tout représentant de l'État
dans tel ou tel institution amenée à
être porteur dans certains nombre
d'objectifs qui ne sont pas forcément
partager par l'autorité indépendante
là donc effectivement c'est c'est un
sujet important c'est un sujet qui passe
aussi par le Parlement d'ailleurs
puisque les autorités indépendantes
rendent compte au Parlement que vous
aurez le loisir de me m'interroger aussi
souvent que vous le souhaiterez et y
compris de poser des questions sur la
façon dont s'exerce cette indépendance
comment elle s'exerce quotidiennement et
sur tel ou tel sujet donc
bon par ailleurs j'arrive directement de
Bercy alors effectivement oui je peux
pas me renier d'ailleurs j'ai passé plus
de 20 ans au total je pense à Bercy sous
différentes fonctions et dans mes
fonctions actuelles je suis très
éloignée des sujets financiers puisque
mise à part effectivement les questions
de budget du ministère et donc de ceux
qui s'occupent de la réglementation
financière je m'occupe en tant que
secrétaire général des fonctions support
du ministère donc je dirais que d'une
certaine manière je ne suis plus
totalement au fait des objectifs que
peut que peuvent souhaiter défendre ceux
qui sont mais très lointains successeur
à la direction du Trésor et puis
fondamentalement je les connais et donc
je sais qu'ils vont effectivement sans
aucun doute chercher à me donner leur
point de vue et c'est un point de vue
légitime que j'entendrai que j'écouterai
mais
j'exercerai ensuite mes fonctions avec
l'indépendance qui s'y attache elles
sont très différentes des fonctions que
j'ai pu être amenées à exercer y compris
lorsque j'ai enfin notamment lorsque
j'étais au sein du ministère des
Finances donc oui c'est une autre
fonction très différente qui arrive à un
autre moment de ma carrière qui arrive à
un moment justement depuis trois ans je
me suis beaucoup j'ai pris pas mal de
recul par rapport au sujet financier bon
il va falloir que je m'y remette parce
que entre temps les choses se sont la
technique a évoluer mais au-delà de ça
ça m'a donné pouvez aussi pas mal de
recul par rapport à mon parcours
antérieur et je pense de maturité aussi
sur la capacité à exercer en effet ces
fonctions
qui sont
difficiles parce que effectivement il y
a un moment où on travaille en son âme
et conscience encore une fois comme je
l'ai dit dans mes propos introductifs je
n'ai pas l'intention de les exercer dans
la solitude je pense qu'on peut
s'appuyer sur le collège et d'ailleurs
la composition du collège est un sujet
majeur puisqu'il faut à la fois y avoir
des compétences des sensibilités
différentes il y a notamment des grands
juristes en fait autour de la table
c'est important pour pour effectivement
à chaque fois avoir en tête les textes
et fondamentalement au-delà de la
protection du Parlement et du fait que
l'on rencontre au Parlement de son
action il y a la protection qu'apporte
des textes tout simplement je pense que
chaque fois qu'on prend une nouvelle
fonction ce qui est très important c'est
de lire les textes et de imprégner et
ensuite de les appliquer lorsqu'on a des
doutes effectivement de se reposer sur
le collège les services et les sachants
au sein du collège notamment les
juristes
sur la question du verdissement de la
finance alors j'ai peut-être parlé vite
quand je parlais de verdissement de la
finance je parlais de verdissement réel
de la finance je pense qu'on sort d'une
phase de foisonnement qui est plutôt
bienvenu d'ailleurs je pense que les
acteurs économiques dans leur ensemble
que ce soit d'ailleurs les acteurs
financiers ou les acteurs économiques
plus généralement ont été notamment à la
suite de l'accord de Paris convaincue
que si effectivement on voulait avoir
des résultats tangibles sur ce qui se
passait en matière de développement
durable il fallait aussi qu'ils assument
leur rôle après ils l'ont fait de
manière je ne veux pas dire brouillonne
mais ils l'ont fait avec les moyens du
bord c'est à dire
en ayant recours à tel ou tel label il y
en avait de très nombreux à tel ou tel
agence de notation plus ou moins aux
méthodes plus ou moins étayées disposant
de plus ou moins de moyens et évidemment
bon il est il a fallu passer par cette
phase il fallait peut-être passer par
cette phase effectivement où chacun
voulait développer son action je pense
qu'on peut leur faire le crédit de la
bonne foi même si il peut y avoir aussi
ce qu'on appelle maintenant bon français
de des tentations déco blanchement
notamment d'ailleurs sous le l'influence
des épargnants parce que les épargnants
votent avec leurs pieds ou plus
exactement avec leur argent et que donc
ils adressent et ils ont adressé très
vite à un moment où effectivement le
cadre n'était peut-être pas suffisamment
claire et et et
bien établi ils ont adressé une demande
très forte aux acteurs financiers dire
que effectivement les les acteurs
financiers sont des
sont avant tout là pour apporter les
produits qui sont demandés par les
épargnants ou par les investisseurs et
il y a une demande qui a explosé de
produits financiers qui ne nuisait pas
l'environnement ça c'est je dirais la
base et le minimum minimum et si
possible qui permettait d'amplifier et
d'accélérer la transition écologique
c'est d'ailleurs effectivement un des
rôles majeurs des places financières au
sens large c'est de donner les moyens
j'évoquais tout à l'heure les
financements de long terme d'ailleurs de
donner les moyens de financer la
transition écologique qui nécessite des
financements très lourds très important
et si possible volontaire mais on vient
de le voir d'ailleurs au passage avec
avec le plan de relance j'ai lu
récemment une estimation qui a été faite
alors j'avoue je ne sais plus par quelle
économiste mais effectivement sur le les
montants qui ont été consacrés l'année
dans les années précédentes et l'année
dernière
à la transition écologique et pour la
première fois son estimation était qu'on
avait fait le niveau d'investissement
nécessaire pour respecter nos objectifs
mais c'est passé par une part un tiers
du plan de relance qui a notamment
beaucoup abonder ses financements donc
comment faut-il faire bon d'abord la MF
encore une une fois a été très aux
avant-postes en la matière puisque dès
2019 elle a mis en place une commission
spécifique qui permet déjà de mettre
autour de la table les différentes
parties prenantes y compris les
représentants des associations
les représentants évidemment du monde
financier les représentants des
épargnants et des investisseurs pourquoi
parce que il faut essayer de parler la
même langue a été évoqué d'ailleurs
aussi le travail énorme qui vient d'être
achevé à Bruxelles autour de la
taxonomie parce que la question de
savoir de quoi on parle était évidemment
fondamental notamment parce que
évidemment ne va pas fermer nos
frontières enfin il y a pas de
frontières
artificielle sur les propositions qui
sont faites aux épargnants et aux
investisseurs
en tout cas en Europe on est dans un
marché unique et donc la taxonomie c'est
la base c'est à dire que maintenant on a
la grammaire je dirais pour écrire
l'évaluation qu'on va faire des
différents produits financiers ça passe
par la effectivement la
professionnalisation aussi des acteurs
qui font des notations par exemple
puisque ce sont en effet
des sources d'information indépendante
qui permettent effectivement aux
investisseurs et aux épargnants de faire
de faire la part des choses bon après il
y a l'information financière et
extra-financière qui est donnée ça aussi
c'est un chantier extrêmement important
on a longtemps beaucoup travaillé sur
l'information financière à juste titre
on protégeait les épargnants et les
investisseurs face à des risques
financiers aujourd'hui il y a un nouveau
pan qui s'est ouvert de de travail qui
est de les protéger face à un risque que
ce qu'on leur dise sur l'impact de leur
de leurs investissements ne soient pas
totalement
donc là aussi c'est évidemment quelque
chose de beaucoup plus récent les
rapports RSE des entreprises de mémoire
ont été introduites par le Grenelle de
l'obligation de cette obligation a été
introduite par le Grenelle de
l'environnement bon on est passé par une
phase où on a eu presque un peu comme
les prospectus de l'AMF un des rapports
RSE qui sont énormes que pas grand monde
ne lit j'espère que dans l'entreprise
tout le monde les lis mais je n'en suis
même pas convaincu et ensuite personne
ne sait trop quelle conséquence en tirer
donc là aussi il va falloir
effectivement
avoir des raisonnements communs et
partagés moi je crois beaucoup à la
concertation sur ces sujets j'avais
beaucoup travaillé à l'époque sur la
création du Comité consultatif du
secteur financier qui a un rôle beaucoup
plus général qui est pas spécialement
sur la finance verte je pense que déjà
quand les parties prenantes sont autour
de la table et s'entendent on sait de
quoi on parle sur quel langage on se
base effectivement la réglementation
européenne alors
on peut considérer qu'elle est
insuffisante imparfaite ça fera sans
doute partie des sujets qui vont revenir
plusieurs fois moi j'ai bien connu le
les directives bancaires je crois que la
première monte à 1977 je sais plus j'ai
perdu le compte mais je pense qu'on doit
en être à la cinquième 6e 7e directive
d'harmonisation donc il faut simplement
là on peut pas se permettre d'aller
aussi lentement donc il faut aller
beaucoup plus vite heureusement on peut
capitaliser effectivement sur cette
cette expérience on a beaucoup travaillé
les uns et les autres sur comment est-ce
qu'on régule comment est-ce qu'on
catégorise comment est-ce qu'on
considère qu'il y a des labels plus ou
moins crédibles vient d'être mis en
place d'ailleurs un institut de la
finance durable au niveau de la place de
Paris qui va je pense être un des lieux
pas forcément le seul il y a
effectivement la commission de l'AMF qui
qui existe depuis 2019 et qui donc peut
continuer à progresser de manière très
ciblée mais au-delà de ça il faut que
que chacun puisse je dirais confronter
les points de vue arriver c'est à dire
quelques vérités que tout le monde n'a
pas forcément envie d'entendre parce que
encore une fois moi je fais le crédit de
la bonne foi mais
c'est un peu foisonné au départ
tout le monde a voulu faire du vert du
plus vert que vert comme comme on
pourrait dire
aussi et donc il faut maintenant
effectivement qu'on arrive sur la base à
la fois en réalité de texte parce que au
fond la taxonomie c'est un texte c'est
une base maintenant il faut
effectivement capitaliser là-dessus et
puis donner en fait le pouvoir aux
épargnants et aux investisseurs de
d'utiliser à bon escient leur
investissements et leur épargne
puisque encore une fois ce sont eux qui
vont orienter principalement les choses
quand ils vont adresser une demande à
des acteurs financiers ceux-ci vont être
rapidement amenés à rendre compte de la
réalité de ce qu'ils font de la réalité
de la façon dont ils entend remplir les
objectifs qu'ils ont affichés etc à
défaut effectivement il y aura assez
rapidement des des fuites vers d'autres
ou en tout cas des changements de
boutiques dirons-nous plus plus
prosaïquement
sur la prochaine crise alors bon
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas prédire
les crises je pense que personne ne le
sait enfin je pourrais vous en prédire
une avec on pourrait tous d'ailleurs
autour de la table après dire une je
pense qu'à un moment ou un autre nous
aurions tous raison donc voilà plus
sérieusement
j'ai eu effectivement l'occasion de
vivre la crise financière j'étais à
l'époque au Crédit Agricole j'ai vécu la
crise de la dette souveraine depuis
Matignon et j'ai vécu la crise sanitaire
en tant que au fonctionnaire de défense
et de sécurité du ministère j'espère
d'ailleurs que je ne porte pas trop la
poisse en la matière mais bon c'est
effectivement
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de cela
bon d'abord il faut surveiller un
certain nombre de choses notamment les
spread quand on voit les spreads de
marché qui commence à s'écarter beaucoup
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est passé de
manière très accélérée au Royaume-Uni
ça veut dire tout simplement que les
investisseurs et les épargnants qui au
fond même si individuellement ils sont
pas tous très avisés collectivement ils
ont quand même une vision assez assez
clair de ce qui se passe quand il
commence à mettre en doute le fait que
l'émetteur quel qu'il soit en
l'occurrence c'est un État souverain ne
risque de ne pas être en mesure de
rembourser sa dette là on a une alerte
réelle qui se produit et donc
effectivement alors ça veut pas dire
qu'on peut pas la résoudre heureusement
les crises ne sont pas totalement
instantanées au passage s'il y a des
tentations effectivement sur les marchés
d'accélérer la crise avec des
comportements très rapide parce que tout
le monde est pris de panique ou parce
que tout le monde suit ce qui se passe
chez le voisin ce qui est une tentation
qui peut exister les autorités de
contrôle et de régulation disposent d'un
certain nombre d'instruments
effectivement pour faire circuit et
permettre à tout le monde de reprendre
un peu ses esprits de se calmer et de
regarder la réalité des choses parce que
par ailleurs je ne suis pas grand-claire
mais je pense que le Royaume-Uni est un
pays qui a toujours remboursé ses dettes
et aura vocation à le faire
et puis plus longtemps que la France
bon donc plus donc effectivement
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire
je pense qu'il faut effectivement être
très vigilant parce que la période est
troublée parce qu'effectivement on va
avoir des investisseurs qui vont aller
chercher du rendement et qui donc vont
aller chercher du risque donc on va
probablement avoir une montée
de des risques sur sur les marchés parce
que le contexte de taux qui a été stable
alors de manière bonne ou mauvaise c'est
pas moi de le dire mais en tout cas qui
a été stable pendant plusieurs années
avec des taux extrêmement bas évoluent
et il évolue vite parce que l'inflation
aussi vient vient perturber la recherche
de rendement donc ce sont des
indicateurs en fait qu'il faut suivre et
puis après effectivement
il faut espérer qu'on n'entre pas dans
une vraie crise qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une crise ben c'est le moment où on
commence à avoir peur de ne plus
maîtriser la chose moi je me souviens
très bien que quand à l'été 2011
souvenir très fort très personnel quand
on de réveiller le matin après avoir
assez mal dormi pour dire les choses on
se demandait si la zone euro allait
encore passer la journée c'était
l'époque je le rappelle ou d'une part
notre nous étions sur le point de perdre
notre triple A alors sans doute qu'on
s'était un petit peu exagéré l'impact de
la perte du Triple up puisque on a
survécu mais c'était aussi l'époque et
je tiens à le rappeler où on n'avait pas
encore eu le discours de juin 2012 de
Mario Draghi qui était le discours
whatever it takes et qui a montré
qu'effectivement le prêteur en dernier
ressort sur les marchés et vis-à-vis des
du système financier quelle est la
banque centrale a des outils et peut les
utiliser et siffler d'une certaine
manière la fin de la récréation par
rapport à ceux qui peuvent effectivement
être être amenés à amplifier les
mouvements de marché en spéculant mais
l'époque dont je parle c'est l'été 2011
et donc à ce moment-là nous n'avions pas
cette sécurité
et donc nous devions nous reposer sur
nos propres forces sur notre capacité à
convaincre qu'effectivement nous
rembourserions notre dette et je peux
vous dire que ça n'était pas très facile
surtout après que la Grèce puis le
Portugal puis l'Irlande ce soir
retrouver dans la situation où
effectivement il n'avait plus un accès
suffisant au marché et quand je parlais
des spreads effectivement on le voyait
quotidiennement avec l'écartement des
spreads et je vous rappelle qu'à
l'époque il y avait des grands pays de
la zone euro qui étaient considérés
comme potentiellement en risque de se
retrouver dans la même situation
j'oublie de dire qu'entre temps il y a
eu effectivement une réglementation
financière extrêmement forte qui est
venu quand même combler beaucoup des
insuffisances qui pouvaient exister à
l'époque notamment sur la gestion de la
liquidité on sait que ce qui génère la
crise ça peut être des problèmes de
solvabilité je ne crois pas que vous
allez rembourser et ce qu'il a déclenche
partout est toujours c'est le problème
de la liquidité c'est les manprothers je
ne peux plus payer donc à ce moment-là
effectivement tout le monde panique et
on peut voir les phénomènes que vous
avez suivi comme nous tous
malheureusement
sur le
les crypto monnaie et la réglementation
européenne alors vous faites allusion je
pense au règlement Mika qui est en train
d'entrer en vigueur et c'est un
règlement qui va être assez exigeant
d'ailleurs se posera la question de la
transition pour pour les acteurs qui ont
été enregistrés en France sur la base de
la réglementation France française donc
bon c'est toujours difficile
excenté
d'anticiper complètement sur l'impact
qu'aura ce règlement puisque il n'est
pas encore en vigueur donc il faudra
effectivement qu'on le suive avec
attention et qu'on voit effectivement si
ça permet d'avoir un marché
assainie puisque là encore bon on a
parlé de l'innovation c'est évidemment
un sujet il faut pas il faut pas
étouffer l'innovation ça passe toujours
au départ par une forme de foisonnement
et de et de de créativité parfois un
tout petit peu débridé bon même si il
faut pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain en l'occurrence
une fois qu'on aura des acteurs qui
effectivement vont passer par la voix de
l'agrément et de voir se conformer à un
certain nombre d'obligations sur le de
transparence etc je pense que les là
aussi les les on aura donné aux
épargnants et aux investisseurs le
pouvoir dont ils avaient besoin et puis
bon c'est un peu tôt pour pour juger de
ce règlement il faudra il faudra le
suivre avec attention je suppose
d'ailleurs que c'est une des choses à
laquelle le Sénat s'attachera sur le
lien avec les autres autorités de
régulation
l'argile la caisse les questions de la
publicité
c'est effectivement un des sujets que
j'ai évoqué parce que je pense que
chaque autorité à sa légitimité et son
rôle en revanche elles peuvent avoir
quelques savoir-faire qui peuvent par
analogie être intéressant c'est pour ça
que j'ai parlé effectivement
de l'argile qui est devenu maintenant
l'autorité nationale des jeux d'ailleurs
puisqu'elle a étendue son champ mais
c'est très récent
pourquoi parce que effectivement
dans un certain nombre de domaines
heureusement pas tous on peut avoir des
situations où on est pas très loin des
comportements addictifs on n'est pas
très loin de publicité qui font appel un
peu au même ressort que ce du jeu
l'autorité nationale des jeux a réussi
effectivement à traiter ce type de sujet
et donc je ne dis pas qu'on est il faut
pas effectivement confondre le jeu est
les placements et l'épargne bon c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être un des messages
importants c'est que au jeu alors je
suis moins experte en matière de jeu je
dois dire mais je pense qu'au jeu on
peut tout perdre et on le sait en
matière de placement financier il y a
quand même assez peu de domaines dans
lesquels on peut tout perdre mais il y
en a donc il faut le savoir il faut le
dire mais effectivement il faut qu'on
fasse attention à ce que tout ça ne
devienne pas complètement virtuel et que
effectivement les gens se retrouvent du
jour au lendemain n'ayant perdu leur
petit le petit peu d'épargne qu'ils
avaient devant eux en ayant un peu le
sentiment tout ça était très ludique
très virtuel bah non une fine et la
facture arrive à la banque et
[Musique]
il y en a plus de livrer à voilà donc je
pense que effectivement il faut
s'inspirer on n'est pas dans le même
domaine bien sûr mais il faut s'inspirer
peut-être effectivement du travail qui a
pu être fait dans ces domaines là y
compris d'ailleurs sur la publicité
je crois qu'il y a eu ensuite une
question avec qui connaît la MF alors
c'est vrai que j'ai eu pas mal de
félicitations sur sur mon arrivée à
l'Association des maires de France donc
bon je vois qu'il y a un petit sujet
effectivement
il faut il faut en effet continuer à
avoir une politique de communication
active donc pas tellement pour faire de
la publicité pour l'AMF et pour que
l'AMF soit connue et que surtout ceux
qui peuvent avoir besoin de se référer à
ce qu'elle fait et d'écouter sa parole
puisse en effet l'identifier donc une
fois qu'on a dit ça ça n'est pas simple
j'ai évoqué quelques pistes tout à
l'heure en évoquant les nouveaux canaux
de communication qui sont utilisés par
d'autres et que la MF aussi doit savoir
utiliser
sur les la proximité ne pas oublier les
territoires c'est très important il y a
pas que à Paris qui a des marchés
financiers il y en a effectivement
d'autres endroits du territoire donc
effectivement c'est un dialogue qui qui
faut avoir
même si effectivement en matière de
marché financier peut-être moins que
pour d'autres autorités financières dont
les acteurs sont présents absolument
partout sur le territoire l'AMF a besoin
de se démultiplier mais je pense que
effectivement j'avais eu l'occasion de
me rendre alors je crois qu'il y a une
bourse qui s'écrit il y a pas très
longtemps à Lille il y en a une à Lyon
évidemment il y en a dans plusieurs
métropoles moi ça fait partie des choses
que je que j'aurais accorde à coeur de
faire d'aller voir effectivement les
acteurs locaux qui est de comprendre
quels sont leurs problématiques et leurs
attentes
enfin
on a parlé des crises et de des
crypto-monnaies oui pardon je ne
voudrais pas jeter moi-même la panique
donc monsieur capo canelas a évoqué m'a
demandé de qualifier la situation
actuelle non nous ne sommes pas en
situation de crise il n'y a pas de il
n'y a en tout cas sur les marchés
financiers rien n'est hors de contrôle
on n'est pas passé loin effectivement
d'une situation un peu compliquée au
Royaume-Uni mais pour le coup on n'est
pas en situation de crise ou
effectivement on peut être amené à se
dire qu'il faut dégainer un certain
nombre d'outils et de coupes circuit
voilà merci
bien merci
Gérard Longuet oui
merci monsieur le président de cette
session de repêchage
madame le secrétaire général
comment réagirait selon vous comment
doit réagir selon vous l'AMF en matière
de financement qu'il s'agit de verdir
s'agit-il de les verdir ou de faciliter
la décarbonation des investissements
et quelle autorité vous donneriez vous
en la matière
alors vous avez évoqué la taxonomie
c'est donc ce à quoi je fais une vision
directement
il faut regarder son mandat d'abord
effectivement en tant qu'autorité
indépendante je parle comme je l'ai dit
je pense que le rôle de l'AMF au delà
des convictions qu'on peut avoir les uns
et les autres sur ce qu'on peut
souhaiter faire c'est de donner du
pouvoir aux épargnants et aux
investisseurs donc la manière de leur
donner du pouvoir c'est qu'il dispose
d'une information
incontestable réaliste pour mettre leur
argent là où ils peuvent souhaiter le
mettre après il y a des choses qui
ressortent des pouvoirs publics et
notamment du gouvernement si le
gouvernement veut interdire telle ou
telle investissement
à des acteurs économiques tel ou tel
activité par exemple ou de le
financement de tel ou telle activité ça
c'est effectivement le rôle des pouvoirs
publics et je fais bien la distinction
en effet puisque la question m'a été
posée
l'autorité indépendante n'a pas de
pouvoir de réglementation ou de
législation d'ailleurs un sujet qui est
à mon avis même si je n'y ai pas plus
travaillé que cela avant de vous
répondre plutôt du niveau législatif
parce que si on devait aller vers des
interdictions par exemple de d'investir
à tel ou tel endroit on est
effectivement face à des libertés
fondamentales donc là on est on est très
au-delà de ce que peut faire une
autorité indépendante après l'autorité
elle aura à vérifier effectivement que
les décisions qui ont été prises que ce
soit d'ailleurs au niveau national ou au
niveau européen même si je suis
convaincu mais c'est une conviction
personnelle que le niveau européen et le
niveau pertinent pour les raisons que
j'ai évoquées d'ailleurs parce qu'il est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir des
frontières pour les investisseurs ou
pour les épargnants donc
l'autorité devra effectivement s'assurer
que les réglementations sont respectées
que les la taxonomie est effectivement
utilisée pour qualifier les différents
types d'investissement et donc ensuite
le cas échéant informé si on a le
sentiment que ça n'est pas le cas par
exemple
très bien merci beaucoup madame pour vos
propos et les réponses à la fois très
précises et très complètes que vous avez
apporté à nos collègues et je vous
propose quand vous raccompagne pour que
nous puissions ensuite procéder au vote
pour un dépouillement qui aura lieu
demain matin à 9 heures
ok monsieur le président